now the nobel peace prize for this year
has been awarded to two journalists
maria ressa of the philippines and
dmitry muratov in russia
ms ressa and mr muratov
are receiving the peace prize for their
courageous fight
for freedom of expression in the
philippines
and in russia
at the same time
they are representatives
of all journalists
who stand up for this idea in a world in
which democracy and freedom of the press
face
increasingly adverse conditions
well let's bring in our asia
correspondent siobhan robbins who is in
bangkok and diana magnay who is in
moscow for siobhan to you first maria
ressa a journalist in the philippines
i've met her she's fearless isn't she
scrutinizing at the government of
rodrigo duterte just tell us a bit more
about her
well sam you know all too well how
fearless she is she's a real firecracker
she's a veteran journalist veteran
correspondent and in 2012 she co-founded
the online
news site rappler
but really the pressure that she's been
facing in the philippines over the last
few years intensified following the
election of rodrigo duterte and her with
the rappler staff did intensive
investigations into
extrajudicial killings human rights
abuses linked to duterte's war on drugs
also exposing what she said was an
online
troll army basically which was pushing
fake news around his presidency and
since then both her and the rappler
staff have faced more than a dozen legal
cases yet it hasn't deterred her she's
continued to fight for freedom of the
press and it's interesting that today
when she was actually getting that award
she was online doing an online forum a
chat about freedom of the press and you
see her suddenly saying oh someone's
calling me a few minutes she comes back
and she just says that she's speechless
uh that it just shows how tough it is
and that this is for all of the other
journalists in the philippines and i
think many journalists in the
philippines will be buoyed by this
because many are reporting that it's
becoming extremely hard for them to do
their job and this was her message to
them
journalism has never been as important
as it is today and yet it is so
difficult to do the job that we had set
out um
in order to keep doing what we're doing
keep the north star ahead of you you
know you
protect the facts
you hold power to account
you
exercise the rights that is in the
philippine constitution
that's what we did and that's what we'll
keep doing
she's keeping on going isn't she diana
let's talk about the other journalist
recipient the editor of an independent
russian newspaper which has seen several
of its journalists killed
that's right he's editor-in-chief of
novi gazietta which is really the uh
most well-known longest established
independent newspaper pretty much the
only independent uh outlet that has
still not been labeled a foreign agent
in what has over the last few months
been a real
escalating crackdown on
the freedom of the press here in russia
and as you said navier gazietta it was
established in 1993 and dmitry muratif
was one of its
founders back in the day when they
really didn't have much beyond a couple
of computers and a few
seats and interestingly and quite a nice
symmetry um michael gorbachev who owns
part of novio gazietta donated part of
his nobel peace prize prize money to
novio gazetta as it was getting going um
to to to to get it going in that time
six of novio gazetta's journalists have
been killed doing uh their work which
has been a really fearless
um endeavor to expose corruption to
expose human rights abuses
yesterday marked the 15th anniversary of
probably the most famous of those
reporters anna polikovskaya's murder
here in moscow she had been probing for
a long time human rights abuses in
chechnya and that 15-year mark
marks the expiration of the statute of
limitations on
her murder no one has ever been held
accountable and we heard today from
dmitry muratov that this prize for him
is is not just for him it is for all of
those who've def who've died uh
defending their
all of our right to freedom of
expression and he also said that he was
going to give some of that prime prize
money to
children with uh spinal muscular
dystrophy
um and also to journalistic activities
and that he would do what he could to
fight for all those other outlets who've
been called foreign agents because just
as in the philippines it really is a
very very tough time for independent
journalism in russia the authorities are
very much cracking down on it every
friday practically we've seen more media
outlets named uh foreign agents will be
interesting to see if navigator manages
to escape that label um today the
kremlin uh commented on uh his award and
called him a talented courageous
journalist i don't think that is a label
that um mr muratov is particularly going
to
care about what the kremlin says because
as the committee said he has stood
fearlessly uh and championed in
independence uh and a continuation of
holding the government to account
and exposing abuses of the regime
throughout his more than 20-year career
at a very very difficult time in russia
and i struggle to think of any other
outlet journalistic outlet in the world
which has seen six of its reporters
killed and i think that shows you um
just
the kind of work that navia gazetta does
here
okay diana in moscow siobhan in bangkok
thank you very much the nobel peace
prize this year just to reiterate
awarded to two journalists maria ressa
of the philippines and dimitri muratov
in russia